[Applause]
welcome back everybody it is black
panther review time i'm ash carlson
joined by our resident black panther
reviewer angelique Jackson thanks for
coming I bet you're having me I'm so
thrilled to be here
the film is simply legendary now I
called it inexpressibly beautiful
because I was being really really extra
on Twitter but it really is a film that
is iconic I think that it's a great step
forward in the MCU and a great
introduction watching this film was a
complete experience and it was an
experience as a black person seeing this
many African people people of color
black people on the screen and that's
what most people are going to be talking
about coming into the film because it is
Marvel's first stand-alone film
featuring a black superhero we got to
meet black panther of course in civil
war but this is a movie that is all
about the people of Wakanda and I think
it's very important that Marvel is is
having this at this time I mean
obviously the film is coming out in
February it's Black History Month it
couldn't really be a better moment but
also it's coming forth during a time
where we're talking a lot about race in
our country and in the world and it's a
really great representation of the
culture and for little kids everywhere
to want to dress up as Black Panther
black white at 8 that mean everyone
across the board is the yeah I did about
this film was there a moment in a
spoiler-free sense that you were
watching it you were like wow this is a
moment that means so much to me I think
the moment that was the most important
we're probably the scene at the
waterfall when you can just see scores
and scores of black people and it's
beautiful because the film takes place
in Africa that's where Wakanda is but
they didn't necessarily have to do that
they could have tried to do something
else with this film all together but
they stuck so true to the story and made
it a really important plot point to
feature everyone in this way I also want
to talk about the director for a minute
cuz we've got Ryan Coogler here who is a
genius as we know but he is 31 years old
directing a Marvel film
I believe unless there's somebody I'm
not thinking about he's the youngest
Marvel Cinematic Universe director I
think you were correct on that for sure
and what's interesting about it is that
Marvel went to a number of other
minority directors including Ava
Duvernay John Singleton and F gary Gray
before eventually landing on ryan
coogler as the director this is a film
that has been in the works really since
the 90s when Wesley Snipes said he
wanted to play black panther so it's
really cool to see that it landed with
this young director who is really
getting a chance to prove himself and
show what he can do to the audience and
something also that's cool about having
Ryan Coogler do this film was that
support that he got from all of those
directors that we mentioned previously
at the premiere they were all there
because they all wanted to see what he
did with this story so I saw the movie
at a screening on the Disney lab which
was lovely but you were at the premiere
I was very lucky to be amongst the first
alongside you to see the film but I got
to see it with the cast with so many of
the celebrity guests and it was just an
experience from start to finish
everyone was gasping cheering laughing
throughout the entire film and I mean
Ryan Coogler got a standing ovation in
the Dolby theatre before her anything
even came up on the screen just him
walking out was simply that exciting oh
my gosh I can't even look like just
watching that red carpet and seeing what
everyone was wearing it was just so like
no let's talk about the red carpet for a
second yeah let's talk about it because
they said royal attire and they really
showed up and showed out everyone on
that carpet was wearing the most
glamorous colors the as much traditional
African garb as they could come up with
it was a really beautiful sight to see
and to see it be done in such a
high-fashion way it was really exciting
yeah okay let's dive into some of the
more specifics of the movie the
characters and whatnot starting with
T'Challa Black Panther okay what do you
what did you make of like his character
progression in this movie versus what
the character that we met in Civil War I
actually just we watch Civil War trying
to get a last night I'm trying to get
kind of like a scope of how we've got
introduced to jacala
and he was always very regal and posture
and and seemed like he was a very
like put together guy but what is great
about this film is it really takes them
through that personal journey of
becoming King because in civil war we
see him a lot wanting to enact vengeance
for his father's death and that's really
what it's all about
this is him coming into his own as a man
as a king at one point there's a line to
describe T'Challa saying it that he is a
good man with a good heart and it's hard
for a good man to be king and that's
kind of what he's trying to overcome and
figure out who should I surround myself
with how do I make these decisions how
do I live up to my father's legacy but
you know advance things forward yeah and
it's kind of why this movie works so
well I think it's because it's a very
universal story in that way because it
is really just a story of this guy
growing up and coming into his power
let's talk about the villain of the
movie oh we've got Eric kill monger
Michael B Jordan Michael B Jordan Ryan
Coogler darling I mean listen we were
all really excited to see Ryan and
Michael team up again of course they
work together on Fruitvale station and
Creed we know that Michael is an amazing
actor but he takes this villain level to
a whole other level Michael B Jordan
said that he actually looked to Heath
Ledger for inspiration while playing
this character and we all know that
Heath won the posthumous Oscar before
playing the Joker in the Dark Knight and
is a really bold prediction but he is
good enough that he could be in that
kind of consideration next February I
feel like I agree with you I really wish
I mean I get frustrated with the Academy
every year with like you know they
picked the Oscar bait movies and they're
like some of these performances are
amazing and I really hope that that
performance is recognized at it at least
who won awards you exactly definitely
deserves it and I mean my biggest
criticism of every Marvel movie is
pretty much the villain yeah it's you
know they have these big world
domination villains that just want to
take over the world for whatever
vindictive reason they have very
cartoonish and this one was just so
grounded and you understood all his
motives and it was it was really sad it
was really political and it was but in a
good way now I'm like a it's political
yeah no it's good political but it was
like you wept for this person that is
what you're supposed to be
against absolutely and I think that's
kind of the genius of his portrayal
because you get that he has a back story
he has reasons everything that he's
doing is because of his background and
and I think that's also what makes him a
good fo for T'Challa is because they
know Michael has been you know going
around saying that it's like Professor X
and Magneto where they both want to
achieve the same goal to have crazily
different methods for doing it and Erik
kill mongers very militant about what he
wants to have happen moving forward and
two challahs different he has to be more
diplomatic and it's really interesting
him having to deal with that so early on
in becoming King because it really
forces him to decide this is the kind of
King I want to be yeah and don't get me
wrong like he's a terrible person but oh
so good oh my god because you know I
think about the other Marvel villains
it's like people love Loki of course and
I liked vulture and spider-man
homecoming and it's like why do you like
them versus the other villains it's
because their stakes are so much smaller
it's like this small like I just want
the stakes are we try not to say exactly
he wants but the stakes are real they're
grounded in reality versus being like I
just want the world to be mine and all
the Avengers to die exactly that's then
and that really is the key here is
having that realistic portrayal and I
think that also grounds the story too
because the world of Wakanda
seems so far-fetched and it seems so far
off from our world today and kind of not
at the same time totally totally I know
but please go on no I just felt like
it's it's such this this you know the
whole premise of Wakanda is it's this
this hidden high tech world that you
know no one really knows about like what
Condon is seen for the rest of the world
has let third world country that you
know doesn't have anything and then you
go into it it's kind of hidden and it
has the best tech in literally
everything I think you could ever
imagine is in Wakanda but they yeah they
keep it to themselves because they can't
get involved in your politics they are
very much Switzerland evangelise what
Searle in might have to get involved yes
sorry but no it was like it's this kind
of crazy concept but it
also grounded in this in this very real
thing especially when they start to get
political with it you just start
comparing it to things so you're like
yeah Switzerland and it's really I think
important to do that because they could
have made it so fantastical and so
over-the-top and I think making it
grounded is also what's gonna make it
timeless hopefully I mean well actually
hopefully a lot of the issues that it's
addressing in the film aren't issues in
the future but if they are and just even
just from a historical perspective I
think it's really important to just show
it and let it and kind of let it be
versus make it something that was kind
of like wild and crazy yeah I agree with
you
well besides these these men that are
great we also have some very very badass
kick-ass amazing women some of the best
Marvel female characters ever I I feel
like that for me aside from just seeing
the representation of black people was
the most important element of this film
obviously it's about black panther it's
about these two men at odds but behind
them and really next to them are the
women who are fully realized in every
way they're strong they're beautiful
they're incredibly intelligent and they
also have the ability to love and be in
love and if that's part of their journey
that's great it's it doesn't have to be
one or the other with these women and
all of these actresses I mean from the
moment that they announced the cast from
Angela Bassett and Lupita Nyong'o we
everyone a said oh okay this is gonna be
great
ya know I it's like it when I'm watching
the movie it's like the character of
T'Challa is very important and it's like
you know the the titular character of
the movie but at the same time my focus
was on all of these women yeah that was
that were standing next to him as he
said specifically well there's three but
then let's talk about Sheree first of
all yes the play by latisha right she is
the smartest person in the universe I
think probably in the universe not just
in Wakanda but straight up in the
universe Jerry is the tech goddess and
actually the princess of Wakanda which
makes her a Disney princess let's just
note oh my god that's true I mean how
cool right so she is just a brilliant
mind who is
you know using that vibranium yeah his
advantage I believe she's 16 years old
but yeah she's definitely a quick
reporter than Bruce Banner and Tony
Stark definitely they could learn
something from her can you imagine that
brain truck that is what I want is in
infinity war for them to be like we need
like some help and then and then she was
like I know somebody and then Bruce
Banner and Tony Zucco just like she does
like makes them her minions she's like
fetch me this get that because I mean
she's so incredibly brilliant and so
funny yeah and what I also liked about
Sheree was that she really feels like
the cue to T'Challa James Bond you know
obviously they have that brother-sister
relationship but she is the most
brilliant technician and it's really
nice to see her going around the lab and
kind of showing off her weird it is not
all politics that is not all seriousness
it's not on action it is really funny
and the tesha does a brilliant job
acting alongside Chadwick and making
their scenes late yeah brother and
sister I mean you see that little
handshake that they have in the trailer
it's like you've gifted a million times
I know most giftable moment came from a
Quay in the casino best fighter in the
Marvel Universe again I seriously think
she was fighting in like fast-forward
I've never seen anyone move as quickly
as deny does in this film and it's
absolutely insane she's just bonkers
goods but one thing I will say about
that scene is it's also really
impressive for the director in the
cinematographer because I swear to you
there are some of the craziest camera
moves in that scene lots of unbroken
takes and that's you know I wanted to
give a shout out to that Rachel Morrison
and her Oscar nomination who also shot a
spy payment there yeah and there's a lot
of camera movements of that movie that
were just really like mind-blowing to me
this one's in the trailer but when when
you see he's like walking to the throne
and it's upside down beautiful okay so
with the coy yet I love her because
she's she's not a superhero totally you
know but she is in my opinion what would
you like to see from her in future films
it's a really good question I would love
to see more in general from the dormer
Lodge obviously she's the general she
commands this force of amazing badass
women who are
to the bodyguards to the king I mean how
cool is it to see this group of these
beautiful in this case bald black women
with these Spears that fight together
supporting Wakanda and that they are the
main warrior force me we're seeing that
a lot more in in comics and and that's
been part of the universe always but
it's really cool to see it on the screen
absolutely let's not overshadow Nakia
let's not you know Lupita Nyong'o is an
Oscar winner brought a lot of clout to
this film but she's a war dog she's a
spy she gets to kind of show off a
different side that I feel like the
Lupita we all know I mean yeah she can
still rock like a a crazy beautiful gown
but she's also badass and really smart
and savvy and loves to be out in the
world and that all really culminates and
pays off for that character like you see
her kind of building and being like is
she just like someone he likes so
totally know she's way more than does a
love interest cool do you have any
criticisms of the film my only criticism
I feel like I kind of mentioned a moment
ago is that it's a hundred and
thirty-four minutes long and there's a
lot in there there's a lot to unpack and
that's not necessarily a bad thing but
there are definitely moments where
you're like oh this could have been the
end this could have been the end this
could have been the end this could have
been the end but when you think about it
there was no guarantee of a second movie
truly I mean they can always cancel
things around the sleep but I think they
just threw everything every bit of lore
in there that they could and I thought
that you know well it's it's long you
know it's still brilliant it's suddenly
I mean but not just black panther it's
like a lot of these blockbuster movies
are long because I'm always like you
know movie should be over two hours no
but I think I need to see it again
because it's the same thing I had with
the last Jedi where like you're watching
it and they're going back and forth
between all of these plot points that
are gonna eventually culminate at the
end or towards at the climax right and
you're kind of like okay when are we
gonna get there when are we gonna get
there so when they keep cutting back to
some where we've been before you start
feeling that pacing issue where it's
like oh my god we're back here like we
saw their gotten to the point but then
you know when move with when movies are
like that and I go back and watch them
I'm like oh this is very important
because we need a and B to be able to
get to see and this is a very good
character moment for this person so I
kind of want to watch it again with that
lens of knowing how things are gonna
come together and knowing that this kind
of slower moment is very very important
and here's why
actually that is very true because the
whole film is a lot of you know
callbacks or flash forwards if you will
if you notice that things are you know
nice foreshadowing as to what's to come
but yeah it does a few times when you're
going back and forth you're like we
could have just stayed here red going
here but you realize that it is all part
of that master plan meanwhile during
this entire movie uh-huh we have a
soundtrack and a score that is wonderful
absolutely incredible music and not just
because Ryan of course has worked with
his composer in all of his films but
because somehow he enlisted Kendrick
Lamar KDOT people to do the soundtrack
to curate the soundtrack for Black
Panther I feel like people were excited
about the movie people are excited about
the casting and then when the news came
in the Kendrick Lamar was going to be a
part of this everybody just like
exploded like I just what spoiler free
if you can't say it just be like kind of
vague about it what was the most
emotional moment of the whole movie
career there's a moment with like a Sun
Rise the boys of the sunset I'm not sure
there's a moment with the staff yet
where I literally was weeping yeah yep
that is the correct response to that
moment I know exactly when you're
talking about I feel like for me another
great moment was there's a scene with a
koi a and Nakia and they're really kind
of hashing out their place in this in in
all of this as women and as members of
oh yeah I thought that that was really
cool because like I said these women are
so fully realized they actually get to
have this minute between the two of each
other that is really equal to what I
well equal in ideology to what I feel
with kill longer and T'Challa because
they're it's not an argument about like
who's better or who's this but it's like
what is the best step forward for us
right and I just thought it's cool to
get to see two women just have them
that's also what we call passing the bed
test station all across the board so for
you at the moment and it's kind of like
when you're coming off just seeing a
movie you're like it's the best movie
I've ever seen yeah I like but do you
have a current ranking of where Black
Panther ranks for you in the MCU so I
don't have like an actual ranking of my
MCU films but I would 100% put this in
the top five there's actually a moment
right after I left the theater are is
like is this the best MCU movie ever I'm
not positive that it is but it is so
brilliant and it's so important that I
think it doesn't matter it doesn't have
to be the best I mean every moment of
any movie is not gonna be perfect but I
thought this was pretty darn close we
really darn good I kind of do the same
thing like I don't rank one two three
four five I kind of do like a these
movies mean a lot to me these ones are
more action II but not my favorites mine
kind of go like phase one that yes but I
put it with like Doctor Strange
guardians and which one am I not
thinking of Thor Ragnarok yes I actually
my top five includes many of those for
Doctor Strange guardians the first
guardians even though the second
guardians makes me bawl my eyes out it's
like just uncontrollably and then for me
Civil War I I just love seeing talked
about this before cuz I'm I'm Winter
Soldier civil yeah and most people think
I don't have taste and that's fair
I like a new hope better than empire and
everyone oh yeah
I agree well I think that's about all
the non spoilery things that we could
cover I think so I mean everything's a
spoiler and so you can't even explain it
I've been bothering Daniel Kalia for a
solid year about Sawyer like what to do
like can you give me a chance you can
give me a tease and he kept telling you
no you have being like you don't like
rounded the same thing to me
absolutely and they're right there 100%
right don't watch your you know too much
before you go in let yourself be
surprised but it's it's worth it yeah
well I think I think what we can only do
at this point is that I invite you back
to do
the spoiler episode because I think we
need to have one where we can really
dive into some things that we were like
really trying trying so hard not to tell
you guys I'm so excited to come back
thank you for letting it on you I so
excited I never and everyone know where
they can find your stuff and of course
Angelique does have a review that is up
right now any day I read this review
follow me on Twitter Instagram I promise
I will reply and watch this girl she's
great watch me and of course like all
Marvel movies stay for the credits
there's two scenes and we will talk
about them in a spoiler video if you
want to see that let us know in the
comments hit subscribe for more videos
like this thank you guys so much for
watching